ahora todos ustedes saben cómo acceder y
modificar el don de sus páginas web y
pueden hacer eso por horas y horas pero
por qué hacer eso cuando pueden
programar su página web con el html que
quieren desde el principio porque ahora
pueden hacer todo eso como respuesta a
eventos del usuario y eso es lo que hace
que javascript sea tan poderoso en las
páginas web por ejemplo podrías crear
presentaciones de diapositivas
interactivas que detectan cuando el
usuario presiona un botón
podrías crear juegos de todos tipos que
detectan cuando el usuario presiona
teclas o mueve su ratón para lanzar un
pájaro
puedes procesar formularios y validar
las respuestas del usuario
detectando cuando el usuario teclea en
el formulario
podrías crear galerías infinitas
respondiendo cada vez que el usuario
desplaza a la página
todo esto es posible con los detectores
de eventos de tu página web
el usuario realiza alguna acción como
presionar un botón
entonces el navegador pone en
funcionamiento el evento que resulta de
presionar ese botón
y tu código ya tiene una función
establecida para ese detector de eventos
así que el navegador ejecuta esa función
que son líneas de javascript que quieres
que se ejecuten como respuesta en
esencia esa es la forma en que funciona
y ahora te voy a mostrar realmente cómo
codificar lo en tu página web